he was plotting attacks against
Americans but now we've ensured that his
atrocities have been stopped for good
they are stopped for good I don't know
if you know what was happening but he
was planning a very major attack and we
got him that was President Trump moments
ago explaining why he took action to
kill Iran stop general he says he did it
to prevent a war but his critics are
piling on we appear to be without by the
way I'd say without congressional
authorization entering into another
Middle East war I would anticipate the
Persian Gulf War will begin anew this
one-off action can have unbelievably
horrific consequences number one there
will be dead Americans dead civilian
Americans as a result of this it's not
just servicemembers all American
citizens are now walking prime targets
for Iranian retaliation and some
Democrats even accusing Trump of using
an air strike to distract from
impeachment squad member Ilhan Omar
tweeting so what if Trump wants war no
Stu knows this least a war and needs the
distraction oh my god a distraction
Pete typically when there is something
like this the country comes together you
put politics aside of course they can
have the debate if if the president
should declare war but accusing the
president of using us for a block for
impeachment oh but Trump I mean the the
whole idea of him being the commander in
chief there was a commentator today that
said right action wrong
commander-in-chief and ultimately
doesn't matter the decision that he made
no that was literally Jonathan alter on
another network said that said correct
the implication is I'd rather have the
correct commander-in-chief
meaning Hillary Clinton and the wrong
actions and it sums up precisely how
everyone who isn't a support of this
press the haters of the president view
him
doesn't matter what he does we're gonna
dislike him the reality is though the
commentary there is true he made the
right call he made a call based on
advisers around him who believe this is
an imminent threat and and specifically
because he saw a policy action taken
under the Obama administration
we're sovereign American soil whether
it's a consulate or an embassy was
threatened and not taken seriously
dismissed by an internet video by by the
National Security Adviser later on
ultimately he said if you're gonna try
that and we know what Iran does Iran
forty years ago used the American
Embassy in Tehran as the launching off
point for their Islamic Republic
embassies are meaningful to them its
sovereign American soil he said this
will not happen again
and as a result I'm see the signs in
front of me and I'm gonna compensate I'm
gonna send the Marines I'm gonna send
the 82nd airborne which he did by the
way knowing they had intelligence on
Soleimani that looked like a bit of a
bigger reaction than people thought as a
result but they knew what was coming
next so this was something that was
intentional because he didn't imagine if
he hadn't acted the amount of negligence
he'd be charged with you know if he had
knowing about the gathering threat and
not stepping if there really was a
different imminent threat I mean there
have been imminent threats from
Soleimani for decades for over a decade
we know that that's why I keep harping
on actually wanting to hear more about
this because I think the American people
deserve the knowledge about why this
time was different with all of the
potential downsides that will come from
this strike look III know at Qaddafi in
2011 like there's lots of downsides that
came from that to just step back and say
this is a dead a bad guy who's dead and
that's a good thing because I think the
consequences that come from it could
have far-reaching strategic negative
impacts on the United States that
outweighed the benefit from it I mean
this is the most consequential decision
that an American administration has
taken in the Middle East since the
decision to invade Iraq in 2003 and I
just haven't seen the kind of strategic
planning from the Trump administration
it makes me think they know what comes
out it's one thing to say you know you
need more information but yeah Obama
former administration officials like Ben
Rhodes saying that they question the
president's strategy the lead that and
so that's just that's going to happen
and presidents can't worry about it
right they have to be able to make
decisions based on the information that
they have their responsibility that they
have and the timing and then history
we'll figure that out right that's
that's not for them to worry about right
now the other thing is if he if there
had been an attack based on something
that the president knew about any didn't
then what do you think all the 2020
Democrats would have said instead that
would have been a much different
conversation because they would have
said how much tougher they would be so
it's kind of difficult when these are
things are happening in the middle of a
presidential election to the point that
Allah Hana Omar the congressman from
Michigan said our Minnesota excuse me
that said that maybe president Trump
which is trying to create a distraction
think you could arguably say that's from
September to now the biggest distraction
in America has been impeachment that was
actually a distraction and I also think
that there is more strategy behind us
because of something you pointed out
Pete that in April of 2019 the Trump
administration designates Soleimani in
his group as a terrorist organization so
they've no I think that that probably
you will look back and find in as the
history is written about this time that
there was a lot more strategy to it than
we thought but it can't you can't plan
everything out and so yes we need to
know our thing great and I think that
the point I'd like to make is the fact
that when people say that this is the
escalation what if they're Iran Ian's
been doing they have been steadily in
escalating and become more bolder with
their aggressive actions against us
right starting with the oil tankers and
the nut oil processing facilities and
then US positions and then an all-out
attack in Kirkuk that killed a u.s.
contractor and then an attack on the US
Embassy
so I also don't understand why all of a
sudden out of the blue we questioned the
US intelligence community when
apparently especially in domestic
matters they are to be absolutely
believed at all points it's only because
of Trump's involvement that all of a
sudden were not to believe them we're
not to trust them when they have the
intelligence community has come out they
strongly indicated that a major attack
necessitated a preemption with this risk
so why now all of a sudden do we need
more information
we have coupled with if coupled with
Iranian behavior and decisions in these
last year or so has escalated why
wouldn't we believe that we got